The correct answer is that we're sending the wrong content type header.
If you look at the program we're using, we still have
this line in here which says content type to text plain.
If we get rid of this line, I'll comment it out, save this file--
so we got rid of that line, and when I reload my browser--
aha--now our form is as we expected.
That's because in Google App engine the default content type is text HTML,
which tells the browser that it's receiving HTML and it should interpret it as such,
our text is then interpreted as HTML.
When it was sent as text plain, it was interpreted as plain text,
and the browser showed everything we sent back,
you know--angled brackets and all.
Now--let's see if this form behaves the same way as our old one did.
It's working just as it did before, except the difference this time
is the HTML is served by our live web application running on our machine
instead of just a plain text file.